yes i actually represented um amelia the
woman that you saw in jason's piece um
she brought the first successful claim
against the jehovah's witnesses for
child sexual abuse in the uk and that
was in back in 2015.
and although 10 might seem like maybe a
small number
of cases that reflects the difficulty
that victims have in coming forward
particularly those in the jobs witness
organization because of the two witness
rule and various other factors so how
were you able to
find nine others or how did they find
you
they do have quite a network of a good
support network amongst ex-jehovah's
witnesses and in fact off the back of
reporting on the judgment in amelia's
case um the other victim that you heard
from emily who was actually abused
previously by the same person got in
touch and so it has really been through
really media and reporting that people
have gotten in touch i think it's
important to point out that those people
who have gotten in touch have left the
organization
and obvious off honestly
mostly there's a lot more victims i
believe within the organization who have
not come forward for a variety of
reasons uh one of them being that the
religion practices shunning so if you
decide to leave the organization then
you will be shunned by everybody that
you know including your immediate family
members so that's obviously additionally
a big barrier to victims coming forward
which i don't think was particularly
well highlighted by the inquiries report
so when you were going through
what happened to these victims were you
surprised by what you were hearing
i would say i was horrified
particularly all child sexual abuse is
horrific and you would be horrified by
any of it but i think particularly in
the jehovah's witness cases
what's so horrifying is that time and
time again i've seen
a situation where
they are aware of the fact that there is
an abuser in their congregation and
nothing is done about it and that means
that that abuser goes on to
assault
many many more victims and it's really
tragic and horrifying to see a situation
where you know a child could have been
saved and because they took no steps to
safeguard children
there are more and more victims whose
lives are changed and ruined forever
um let's talk about this report now you
did mention it
reading that is horrific but one would
assume that what you've already dealt
with with these victims you wouldn't be
totally shocked by what you were reading
in this report
no i'm not shocked at all
i'm really pleased that the inquiry did
decide to look at abuse and religious
organizations and settings and
particularly include the jehovah's
witnesses in that which was something
that i was pushing for for a long time
um i think that this is a huge area that
the report highlights that there is
really no oversight of religious
organizations in terms of child
safeguarding there's things that they
should do and
are meant to be doing but they're not
required by law to be doing and this is
an area that we really need to look at
very carefully in order to safeguard
children and vulnerable people
okay um they made some recommendations
too really that um
organizations should have a child
protection policy and supporting
procedures one
is just amazed that in 2021 they don't
and that the government should legislate
to amend the definition of full-time
education to bring any setting um
that is a pupil's primary place of
education within the scope of regis of a
registered school briefly what do you
make of those two recommendations
i think they're helpful but i think the
thing to remember in the context of
jehovah's witnesses which you'll see
throughout the evidence that they
presented to the inquiry in the
inquirer's report as well is that they
insist that they don't separate
children from their parents and
therefore there's no need for them to
adhere to any of these policies and
procedures the truth of the matter is
in in practice that's not true children
are often separated from their parents
and there needs to be other ways to
bring this organization in line with
current child safeguarding policies